نحن هنا شمال محافظه كركوك في كردستان
العراق
136 ضربت المسيره تحت التله لم نفقد
الكثير من الاشخاص تم اطلاق الصواريخ
التي تم ضربها خلال الايام السابقه لكنه
سمح لنا برؤيه مكان الضربه الايرانيه على
قاعده لحزب الحريه الكردستاني في ايلول
سبتمبر الماضي قضى فيها تسعه اشخاص من
المعارضه الكرديه في ايران واصيب 21
تقريبا
فوق راسك هذاك يرى العالم ان ايران قتلت
اشخاصا اكبر سلاح لديهم هو كلاشنكوف ايران
فوق السماء العراق وعلى هذا الموقع
التابعي للتحالف كان يتم وضع مقاتلي داعش
هنا انهم يعبرون السماء ويقصفون مناطق
التحالف
ون من الحدود العراق
نعم اتهام لا ينفيه الحزب فالعلى العكس من
ذلك
لاننا نرى ان النظام وصل الى السلطه بشكل
غير قانوني ويحكم البلاد منذ 43 عاما بشكل
غير قانوني لا نقبل ان تاتي امه فارسيه
اخرى لتحكم الكورد وسنبذل قصار جهدنا
لتدمير هذه الدوله اصيب شاكو خلال القصف
الايراني
التغيير سيحدث ويجب ان يحدث لان الناس لن
يتسامحوا بعد اليوم مع النظام ونحن لا
نقبله
على الرغم من الخوف من ضربات جديده لا
يقبل حزب الحريه الكردستاني التراجع شاكر
تجلى اغنيه عن احلامه باستقلال كردستان
الايراني